and today we're remembering our friend
and colleague and the reason why we're
all sitting here really is not for her I
don't know where most of us would be
many of the view veterans paid their
respects to the series Creator Barbara
Walters who passed away at the age of 93
on December 30th and she started The
View when she was 68 years old very very
few people start a new career at that
age so she really did Define and also
she had no mentors or Role Models
because she was the original role model
for everybody else original panelist Joy
Behar Meredith Vieira Star Jones and
Debbie matanopoulos as well as Lisa Ling
Sherry Shepard and Elizabeth Hasselbeck
reunited to share their memories of
Barbara I mean I'd been watching Barbara
all of my life and here she was sitting
right next to me on my left and it was
just an incredible feeling I mean it was
it always was surreal every time I
looked over Barbara you so protective of
her and I remember Ann Coulter had come
on the show remember when Ann called
again on the show and I just was mad
because she was talking to Barbara I
don't like the way she was talking to
Barbara and I was like you're not gonna
talk to Barbara like that I will yo you
know I'm not playing with you and
current hosts Whoopi Goldberg Sunny
hoston Sarah Haynes and Alyssa Farah
Griffin joined the Alum to celebrate
Barbara's life when I started co-hosting
I was changing my questions on my cars I
don't know if you ladies remember that
and I was changing them and rewriting
them and rewriting them not realizing
that maybe that wasn't appropriate and
she came over to me that's a picture of
it and said what are you doing I said I
this is not my voice I'm rewriting my
question is that okay she said I rewrite
mine yeah and then she started helping
me yeah and I thought my goodness like
the generosity of that moment and I'm so
grateful I'm in my 30s that I always saw
women in Anchor rolls I always saw
females on TV in those presences but
it's because she opened that door that
didn't exist before Barbara Walters in
every sense of the word she was a
Pioneer for someone who gets paid to
talk what she did so well was listen
yeah and when you see what set her apart
her ability to strike that tone between
curiosity compassion Humanity while many
of the View's former panelists joined
the hour-long tribute Walter's former
co-star Rosie O'Donnell was noticeably
missing according to O'Donnell's
spokesperson she was invited to take
part in this special episode but she was
on a plane and couldn't change her
schedule Rosie did share a tribute
online once news of Walter's passing
spread writing what a long and eventful
legendary life she had spoke to every
prominent world leader in memory
interviewed everyone who's anyone and I
was lucky enough to be in her orbit for
a good many years
may she rest in peace and may everyone
remember just what barrier she broke
down for women she was the first and
will always be remembered
[Music]